hey guys it is Friday again which means
I'm here to fill you in on 5 of the
coolest things that happen this week in
gaming let's get into it morrowind is
set to meet skyrim thanks to a very
ambitious group who want to recreate
2000 and tues morrowind easing skyrim's
game engine the elder scrolls renewal
project actually called sky wind is
being created by over 70 people made up
of composers voice actors developers
artists and what have you skywind
currently comes packed with three hours
of Elder Scrolls inspired music ten
thousands of new lines of dialogue and
half of morons landscape recreated
there's a trailer out for the latest
version of the game which you can check
out on teenspot since we're on the
subject game fans really are getting it
done lately with a community remaster of
half-life 2 you can get the free update
on steam now which promises quote
improvements to lighting special effects
increased world detail countless bug
fixes and an original community
commentary mode there's a lovely looking
comparison video so you can check out
what's been changed within the seven
gigabyte update Thank given you won't be
spending a dollar to play it it's
probably worth checking out should you
happen to be a half-life and Microsoft
have dropped their free games with gold
titles for April and although you will
have to wait a couple of days to pick
them up Microsoft have double the number
of games available if you have an xbox
one you can get pool nation FX and child
of light for free Xbox 360 users will be
able to get gears of war judgement and
terraria for free in the first half of
the month and army of two the devils
cartel as well as the SAS ins creed 4
black flag in the second half of the
month from April 16 onwards microsoft
also dropped in the factoids that since
they've launched games with gold more
than 100 million free games have been
downloaded
our report has suggested that Batman
Arkham Asylum and Arkham City are set to
make their way to ps4 and xbox one
before the year is out idn Italy have
claimed that while Arkham origins will
miss the boat the other two Batman
titles will pop up on current-gen
consoles by Christmas if the timeline is
correct this would mean the remastered
editions would land on ps4 and Xbox one
just months after the release of our
tonight which is slated to be the third
and final chapter in Rocksteady's etic
batman trilogy finally blood-borne might
have some spectacular jump scares but
there's a far more terrifying feature
and from software's dark action hit and
that's the character creator the
extremely detailed character creation
tool is a wonderful excuse to create a
character who looks just like you or
conversely to make the ugliest humanoid
you can envision obviously the internet
has gone for the latter our very own
former editor Sean McInnes was
responsible for this monstrosity while
Playstations Andrew Kelly had a few of
his own terrifying contributions neogaf
and reddit have been peppered with all
manner of twisted creations who
certainly off the heroes we wanted but I
guess they're the ones who deserve let
me know down in the comments what gaming
news you cared about this week and which
game you'd love to see get remastered
for PC or console this week on site I
let you know what's so great about
cities skylines onda chips we cover you
off on how to take on Blood Bones bosses
and Lucy commiserates of the games that
won't ever arrive on
minute that is it for me this week be
sure to have yourselves and awesome
weekend and I'll catch you again on
Monday
you